this has been the biggest energy crunch
so far this winter with electricity
Supply meeting Demand only through
Extraordinary Measures by paying
consumers to reduce their consumption
National Grid hope to reduce demand
across the country by 337 megawatts
that's about a third of the output of a
gas power station so it's not much but
it's enough to get the country through
anticipated Peak demand between 5 and 6
PM so let's look at the situation at 5
30 then well the UK was using just over
45 gigawatts of electricity 55 was
coming from gas and coal and 24 from
Renewables and nuclear now that's not
that unusual and whether it can't take
all of the blame it's cold but not that
cold in fact Scotland is relatively mild
is certainly nothing like the freezing
conditions Before Christmas it's also
windier now than it was in the last cold
spell these stronger winds shown in
green and yellow are helping to generate
just under six gigawatts of electricity
from wind farms in the the North Sea on
December the 12th wind generation was
around one and a quarter so it's not as
cold as it has been this winter and our
turbines are turning so what is going on
then well energy analysts say it has a
lot to do with the situation in France
at the start of the month 15 of its 56
nuclear reactors were shut down for
repairs they would normally be a
reliable source of electricity that the
UK could import through cables under the
channel so electricity Supply is tight
and companies are competing for whatever
they can get you can see that in the
market price for much of the day the
wholesale cost has been around 130
pounds a megawatt hour at times of high
demand Breakfast early afternoon and the
evening the cost more than doubled but
the National Grid wasn't sure there
would be enough electricity available
during the Monday Peak even at a high
price and that's why it has for the
first time paid consumers to reduce
demand